huh
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
there you go
a lot of people forget that with a hit
man this is a great hit
it was a great great show you got a
double cowboy for this episode huh you
got a hat
you're gonna do it dude
[Laughter]
but it matches your freaking bandana no
we're the other way michaels
yeah there you go oh yeah man you look
like [ __ ]
but it's awesome though so do i it's
like awesome [ __ ] so do i do
dang man that's cool dude bro you would
have been
a a sheriff maybe
deputy deputy sheriff's assistant huh
he'd be good at that yeah you'd have
been a sheriff's assistant i think no
i've been the guy that watches the uh
okay the inmates
the case you know the guy who's always
saying come on man like
not happening buddy not having buckaroo
yeah yeah hey timothy somebody here to
see you
yeah and who comes to see him who is
this girl
and then i watch them in their conjugal
visits
because they gave me cornbread okay i
respect it okay
i respect it he's got it all mapped out
he mattered he hasn't smelled
just a long time i might have sold this
script to hollywood
it's a new porno wow called you got any
cornbread
you could be like the rockin what what's
that what's the movie the rock dude that
was badass
be cool with johnny knoxville oh
uh walking tall walking tall that one
yeah yeah that was a badass
you used a two by four yeah beat
everybody's ass he refused to use guns
oh yeah yeah and what was that guy he
was a construction worker
uh no he was like a war vet he's a war
vet and came back in like the state of
his town
yeah his best friend was running a
basically a scheme
yeah he went into the casino yeah like a
sneaky man
yeah yeah sneaky real sneaky do you ever
see uh the rock
it's his best performance and be cool we
played the gay dude the gay bodyguard
he's so good in that really and vince
vaughn is all eeweezy
ee weezy he's like come on baby i'm
clowning baby
i'm clowning baby you don't know what
i'm talking about
that's his best role there he is he's a
gay bodyguard it's so funny
oh i remember this whoop that trick
remember no that's that's true
get him whoop that boom find it
come on man find it this up yeah
oh hustle and flow yeah yeah that's a
good one
oh play get one
he's on come on find it
want to emmy for this yeah they did yeah
three six mafia
yeah three ticks get em
get em get em
this is it boy yeah play this at my
cousin's funeral dude
at my funeral dog you want it yeah and
just start [ __ ]
making it rain with my ashes
oh yeah we'll get that ash gun yeah yeah
ooh just like like one of those t-shirt
guns at the nuggets game who's ready to
be here make some noise and you'll come
out jump into a couple flips yep
start it off right and then we'll shoot
your ashes into the
crowd and then you play the chicago
bulls uh theme song before jordan came
out on the starting huh
you know what i'm talking about nick
bring that [ __ ] up
forget the name of it this can play at
my funeral though
see everyone's gonna be sitting down and
the lights can be up this way
thank you for coming thank you for
coming
at 6'4 250 pounds
but now but now 2 ounces
255 pounds knocked out johnny curtis
knocked out johnny curtis he's coming in
at one and a half inches
of inches 2 ounces
from denver colorado
he's big he's brown he's actually
gray now brendan
shoot the ashes into the crowd shoot a
couple t-shirts out there a couple
t-shirts they need t-shirts
king of stinging at funerals a couple
meet me at two ounces shirt
[Laughter]
buzz buzz dad dad shirts that'd be sick
wow
dead gang bro the toughest thing i think
about
dying probably is just
think i think are you just worried about
all your stuff you know
i don't think you give a [ __ ] i mean i'd
be worried about my shoe collection but
outside that
take your shoes look what happens to all
your stuff you know and then where are
you going you go on that that death
journey you know no one knows about it
man
i heard your body that's what i don't
know who says this but they say when you
die
your body release like releases all the
dopamine like all sorts of [ __ ] so you
don't feel anything you just go into
like
like you're basically on dmt dang oh and
you go to where you just
some people go up to the big man some
people go to the bad man
damn and we can guess who's going where
here
yeah this could be hot nick
it's gonna be hot be hot bring your
speed
[Laughter]
place in all beds imagine we show up in
helen knicks down there trying to get a
producer job
somewhere nick's like talking to satan
like look i think
yeah it's you're doing fine but you
could be doing a lot
trying to convince the devil to lose his
money on a parlay
yeah if you want odzimir dude that's
fine i just wouldn't take that
i just you know i won't bet the house
that's all i'm saying
dude nick's picks mike clevenger hit me
up the the pitcher for the uh
indians and was like hey man i need
nick's picks man
oh no [ __ ] yeah well tell them sorry
yeah
yeah bro you gotta run with this
i went one and two this weekend uh
that's not bad
too much confidence on the veterans
nancy smith but they want to work with
frankie didn't work with smith or lawler
it's tough with those veterans how dare
you bet against neil magne
i know i know my boy he's he's a good
fighter it's always tough though with uh
yeah with the vets and then you never
know what's gonna happen
and then also like some weeks the the
fight card just kind of
sucks so like picking it's it's like
it's not fun
but also do better on your picture yeah
yeah yeah but he just got
a couple weeks ago he just got traded to
the um san diego chargers
your boy did yep mike clevenger right
there new san diego padres
padres padres well hell the chargers
probably use it oh damn
the charger there he is bro jay and
silent rob
over here all right dog that dude just
throws he'll
throw shade right over the plate dog
that dude ain't playing dog
oh he's really good oh yeah he's good
he's probably pretty good if he's
playing for the padres you know is he is
he bummed
uh no he's excited because the panthers
are pretty good
yeah the potter's good indians are doing
great and the padres are doing really
great here's the thing though i love
cleveland
not the winner but moving from cleveland
to san diego not a bad
gig you know especially here i mean this
guy looks like a oh dude
get a skateboard cruising down [ __ ]
pb yeah he's in get some phil's barbecue
oh barbecue
i can't believe you're gonna work at
that prison dude yeah
i could see you over there that shirt's
dope man did we sell that
oh my friend gave it to me wow it's cool
my friend i mean you oh yeah
it's the exact shirt i wear in the
cartoon i think also
what's in the uh toonie what is it yeah
hey dude make my cartoon cuter
theo's guy's all cute mine's all shitty
looking dude
make him a little cuter dude i was a
cute [ __ ] kid
nix is funny chins is funny cats is cute
my guy's all shitty looking and he looks
older too well you got held back a
couple times brendan yeah but still
dude it's based on grades would you be
held back no hell no
that's first team all recess bro i used
to wear cleats to elementary school just
for recess
yeah bernie your dude looking hella has
that [ __ ] light mustache coming in
you definitely got held back
i mean according to this cartoon what
are you talking about
come on look at look how cute yours is
you weren't that cute
yes i was dude no you weren't doing
things based on real life you didn't
that is not because i
also i was small as a kid huh i was
small that guy's [ __ ] huge
everything's a problem here today and i
never wore
shorts brittany you ended up as a prison
guard dude
just be happy with how things worked out
that's fair i'm just saying i was first
team all recess
dude were you were you picked uh i
assume you kind of picked in the middle
like
kids liked you but you you weren't
probably the best athlete not the worst
some kid threw a ball really hard one
time and it hit me right in the side of
the head from like point blank range
and i was never the
dude there's nothing worse when you're
on that you know the recess on the field
and your honey's over you got to crush
on one
and you're just trying to talk to a
friend and they're not paying attention
you just feel like they are too that's
the thing
your face is all red and your friend's
like damn dude you're right and they're
laughing like
i'm fine and then you're not fine
everything's ringing
one of your arms is missing it's not fun
dude the crazy thing about being young
you always thought like that the girls
or boys were watching
and they never were well it's kind of
like everyone's too nervous to really
look at each other so nobody saw
anything that's kind of like now like
you think everything's such a big deal
in general people aren't paying
attention dude
not that big of a deal yeah at all yeah
but if you're picked last that would
hurt your feelings man
did you ever cry at school oh yeah yeah
oh yeah i cried you cry
at school yeah yeah i've cried a couple
times okay damn y'all some [ __ ]
though
i never cried at freaking school dude i
needed a little more moisture in my
oatmeal though
he saved it for years later on his
podcast
that's how we [ __ ] that's how we
found it this past weekend
grown men do it that that podcast is
built on blood tears and tears
[Laughter]
i can't believe you little [ __ ] cried
dude
[ __ ] back flipping s day lottery over
here
ryan in the locker room i mean i
wouldn't cry all the time man
but i'd go off on my own and shed some
tears you feel like
you're crying at school yeah i remember
one time i
remember one time i want to fight and i
started crying oh yeah because you're so
happy you won
i was just like just so heated and so
mad and yeah that's those angers just
like
brings the tears out that was like ricky
lamas was that guy's name who won the
other
thomas yeah last two weeks ago he won
and he uh he
almost kind of cried at the end and he
kind of retired almost at the end uh
he was talking about his dad and like
the refugees from cuba and stuff and how
they have to overthrow the dictatorship
it got pretty deep
got a little chatty at the end yeah
but yeah but still man you got to put it
out there yeah that's your platform
yeah people plating out there
everybody's plating dude i um
i'll be honest with you i did trim my
body the other day i did too bro did you
i did too
now when you do it what do you do you go
to a special area do you go outside
inside
i do it all bro i do it all no where do
you do it at
name a body part no no i'm talking where
do you do it at
within the earth oh in my shower oh in
the okay and now when i use manscape it
comes with a little light on it and i'm
like i don't want that to go to waste so
i'll turn out the lights and make it
more difficult
ooh kind of that india just cave diving
kind of jonesing after your indiana huh
yeah i like that man
well look i'll tell you that right now
the manscaped engineer team
just perfected the greatest ball hair
trimmer ever created
the lawnmower 3.0 and thank god
thank god man invented the wheel and
then this manscape thing because i was
making my nuts
when you nick them nuts i've done it and
the blood starts flowing
hopefully i don't bleed out oh yeah and
you can't invite a woman over
you know and nobody's gonna stop that
fight dude you nick you're nuts keith
peterson ain't jumping in herb dean
ain't stopping you from the hands it's
too late
yeah it's too late it's too late we
gotta tell you the manscape boxer briefs
also come with this package they have
optimal temperature control with their
crop cooling technology
keeping your pride and joy supported at
the same time as keeping it cool
you can get 20 off and free shipping
with the code
king sting at manscaped.com
that's right get 20 off and free
shipping with the code king sting
at manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping
at manscape.com and use code kingston
from the moose to the caboose always use
the right tools for the job
dude if you're like me what i'm writing
about food bro
always come on man i'm thinking what am
i having for dinner i'm eating dinner
i'm like why am i having a late night
snack oh yeah
i mean the late night snack what i'm
gonna have for breakfast dude that's a
louisiana tradition man you
you sit down you just fix something to
eat so you can think about what you want
to eat
what's next bro and thank god for
postmates man
thank god and get food delivered without
leaving my house you get all type of
food you want a biscuit
you wanna uh a little uh nut you want a
pistachio with that pf chang's heavy on
the change
dude heavy on the frickin chinese dog if
you want a fruit
you want a collection of fruits you
wanna uh a hot dog
you want a burger you want some sushi
how about how about you want some stuff
from walgreens 7-eleven we got you
covered man and for a limited time
postmates is giving you guys
100 of free delivery credit for your
first seven days that's right you got a
fat husband you got a fat wife a fat kid
get that little ass of biscuits your fat
side piece wants a churro we got ya get
your little daddy get him a little
grapefruit drink
yeah watch your grandma eat a corn on
the couch get him a grapefruit drink
yeah for a limited time only postmates
is giving our listeners
100. a free delivery credit for your
first seven days so
say this say you're gonna the doctor
gives you five days to live
get the code get the money get the post
mates on your way to heaven
to start your free deliveries download
the app and use code kats2020 that's
cats2020 for 100
of free delivery credit for your first
seven years
when you download the poll from march
anything you need anytime you need it
postmates
dude everybody's got a platform now
though everything's like a platform i'm
watching uh
the eco challenge and it's like
um everybody's like you know i'm a i'm a
i have a platform you know
other people have freckles and i have
freckles and what the [ __ ] the eco
challenge
i just don't want any of these any
spotted people to [ __ ] not be able to
speak up for themselves
about 15 12 seconds a little more right
some of that chocolate finish black face
you're right i'm about to find out
right there
is that eddie
say goodbye to that spotify deal
[Music]
but they'd go
who's the editor and that is definitely
eddie bravo
well i hope they i hope they do well
hold on i got to get a picture of that
yeah that is beautiful i hope they do
well
so what do they do this is the the
world's 17 miles just crazy [ __ ] man
but it's 10 days straight and you rest
if you want to
and it's whoever gets to the finish line
first yeah what they may how much they
make
100 100 grand 100 grand it's the hardest
race in the world yeah
before 100 grand i don't know if it's
the hardest in the world
that one in death valley my boy cam
haynes does begs the difference
okay there's another 50 degrees and your
shoes melt
the race to get to heaven is that the
only type of race
maybe or hell at depending that's true
yeah you know what i'm gonna do you know
i just i do last night i couldn't sleep
i'm gonna i'm gonna ride my bike from
san francisco to l.a
five days oh i think the train dude yep
dude ari manas get it on a long board
yeah what wow that's good that's gay
though
here you go right here man later to
san francisco i'm gonna do on a bike i
don't wanna do it on a train
oh somebody's gonna [ __ ] throw
something or hit you with their truck
good chance
i'm have a crew with me though you are
yeah
are you doing a thick boy ride yeah oh
wow which route are you going to take
gca you got to go the coast yeah you got
to go to the coast how how long is that
neck is it saying there
530 something miles should take me about
40 something hours right yeah that's it
four cents
oh yeah okay oh yeah i'm doing like
three four days yeah dude
i'm doing solo dang put my headphones in
the forest gump of bicycling yeah you
got to get a gopro on your helmet oh
yeah i'm have a whole film crew with me
shooting content damn dude so you're
just going to ride over there what are
y'all going to do over there i don't
know i'm just going to ride this bike
to san francisco yeah
pick up hitchhikers on the back of his
bicycle yeah yeah you could do that get
a little side car
you're strong enough pegs bring your
pegs
you'd ride with your boy your boy jump
on the front you're like this is
so hot what are you gonna do up there
man
it's really scary up there yeah i know
it's gonna be sick on this bike
a man threw a bur they had a man one
time i was walking outside had a date
right
a lady just walking her back to
somewhere safe
and this man threw a
dead bird out of his jacket like that
really was he a magician
huh no non-magician in san francisco
yeah must have been tenderloin
and this girl caught her this girl
caught it man
she caught it yeah i think she's like a
little bit native american or something
she [ __ ] caught that thing like that
yeah tenderloin gets a little dicey does
she
does she use it like no she didn't use
it like
i think if you burn it in your house
it's like sage or something
whoa oh it's the people's champ
damn can you hear us
yeah i can hear y'all can i hear me yeah
big uh i got my beats my beats in so i
don't know if this will delay or not let
me know for the delay i'll take them out
on the regular audio sounds great it
sounds good man we're good
man okay thanks for joining us what's
going on in unh town or what
yeah and this time right now dry we
barely missed a hurricane man but we
praying for those who got hit
hey man man yeah it was bad out there
huh
yeah man man it's crazy when you see
like the before and after devastation
pick man it's crazy
and what do y'all do to hunker down do
y'all do anything to hunker down do you
have a plan these days because that's a
regular pattern of behavior over there
yeah man right now it's just uh you know
get your stuff together like
food or supplies stuff but you know you
know how i go
we get we get uh stocked up and have a
party that first night the second night
we
all out all we need to cook all the food
drunk out of beer
[Laughter]
man the hardest part is just like you
know just like kobe just
staying put you know what i'm saying or
or evacuating if you
but the thing is nowadays with so much
like uh you know
subdivisions and things being uh built
the flood patterns change so
areas that used to not flood now they
flood because things have been built so
but when they give that they give that
uh that word to
evacuate boy you better hit that road
[Laughter]
yeah some people you guys got the few
people like nah i'm just gonna stay here
and bunker down
and it never works out for him ever paul
can you give me what do you feel like is
happening with music during the uh
during the covet times like do you feel
like we're gonna catch any type of new
you know like vibes or anything that's
going to come out of this or
are you seeing any of that are you
seeing anybody really kind of find their
own lane with this thing or are you
noticing anything what's
what's up yeah no doubt it's been a big
shift in terms of the creation of the
art of music you know
it was a steady pattern of you know the
way to make music put it out there sell
music the way we consume music all of
that the way we performed as artists and
as fans how we
received it you know it was just a few
different
lanes but it was you know just one
freeway going in one direction
but now with kovit it just opened things
up completely it just uh
it kind of opened uh the the floodgates
you know i'm saying just
for all different types because it's
you're not like restricted to whatever
the
the way the means is you know you can
whatever the trend of fat is you can go
outside of that now
that actually is the time for
non-traditional ways of creating the
music and putting the music like all the
things i said performing at everything
so
you know it's just a it's been an
inspiring time of your artist
it's been a scrambling time if you're an
executive or somebody who's like
more the traditional sense of well how
are we going to put out i mean how we're
going to do it now that things
change but for me i i've appreciated the
fact that
you know it's uh it's it's less
restricted i think you know where
you can try new things that's where i
came from anyway the underground of
you know more where's more raw you know
what i'm saying so now you can kind of
be raw with it because it's an
experimental type of town
you know so there's definitely a lot of
artists out there and also
previous to kovy everybody was you know
busy doing things on the road on tour
whatever got family all of the above
working on new albums doing extra
curricular things outside of music
everything so
now it's like everybody's stuck at home
so where you know we might
previously i might have been extremely
busy now i got time to do songs with
other artists collaborating vice versa
it's musically artistically it's a
definitely a a
a kind of [ __ ] a big shift right now are
you all ready are you are you a fan of
like the the tick tock
uh hooks and stuff like that like the
kids getting the the riffs from tick
tock and then making a full
kind of song i guess yeah
me personally i mean i'm kind of more
traditional but i'm not against it you
know i'm saying
my preference is just more traditional
but you know it's just
with all of the different means of
social media everything it's just
it's just more tools you know more tools
you have you know it's
it's like it's like of a you know van
gogh's painting and all of a sudden
there's a new color
that got invented you know i'm saying
it's like so you can either choose to
use it or choose not to and
you know i'm saying uh it's definitely
that's the newer way if you want to
connect with a like
a lot of people say younger audience but
there's old people on thick socks too
you know what i'm saying
like seals on there still is on there
yeah
paula one thing i noticed about you man
you always stay in such uh
your vibe is always just so positive man
where does some of that energy come from
and has it always been like that was it
was it like that when you were first
kind of starting out or is that
something you've kind of embraced as
you've gone along
man it's i've always just been grateful
for the opportunity to do what i love to
do you know and i've never once
taken that for granted um it's something
that this
is something i played hard for work hard
for still work hard pray hard for
is just to be able to do my dream my
childhood dream to do music you know
what i'm saying so to
be able to have that as a career i don't
take it you know lightly
a lot of people when you know a lot of
times when you become a
not a doctor or lawyer and or a teacher
or something that you can kind of go to
school for get a degree and get a job
or just it don't even have to be dr
lloyd but any traditional job
you know if you do something outside of
that be it athletics entertainment music
acting you know anything like that you
know it's a
it's a different sense you know what i'm
saying it's a hard work ethic but
when you have a a traditional job you
always got people you got to ask them to
you always got to be on time
if you slip up one day you could be
fired if you come to work
late one day you could be probably
wearing entertainment so you know it's
demanding but it's a lot
more relaxed i think but i kind of try
to always take
that professional attitude of man i
gotta be on time i gotta you know take
this serious
although i might be smoking or drinking
or having fun as well i'm really
you know that sometimes that's more to
relax my mind so that i can focus in
other areas you know what i'm saying but
i i don't take it for granted man i
love my job or just to be able to just
do what i love to do man i love it
you've lost a lot of weight paul could
used to be a kind of a thick boy back
maybe you're sipping on that lean which
i'm dying to try yeah
for reals dog i can't wait to get my
lips around some lean but
uh what'd you do get on a bike how'd you
lose all the weight man yeah you used to
be a little more wall
heavy on the wall a little less paul
[Laughter]
yeah man we did a whole lifestyle
transformation me and my wife man
i tried all types of things but
definitely i will say man you know the
partying type of lifestyle it affected
my metabolism other things so
when i'm working out eight hours a day
you know i'm saying running five or six
miles a day on the treadmill
at the park all types of man even when
i'm eating only
fishing playing white rice with no
seasoning i wouldn't lose no weight so i
had surgery i had a
surgery called the gastric sleeve it's
man it saved my life i was uh i was over
320 i was
i was working up to 350. man when i when
i got it get that boy on a bike
right yeah yeah i need to be bored on a
bike
riding with you everybody
so paul i see you also working with some
of these jewelry boys out there man i
see you and uh
johnny out there uh tell us about do you
guys have a a partnership you guys seem
like you guys are
grilling everybody along the south coast
these days yeah and you guys sent me a
pair of
bottom grills which i forgot today
because i have cte but i appreciate it
man
yes sir man that's my boy johnny man
you know we've been doing it now for
over 20 years man working together
he started off doing jury repair he came
here as a
immigrant from vietnam man he got a hell
of a american story man this is the true
american dream
he got family members who were refugees
in the war in the vietnam war you know
they were down with the american side
america gave them refuge
man his family came over here one by one
and they they
a lot of them said not all over a lot of
more in the jewelry business as well and
it's a true story of entrepreneurship
man he came over here doing just jury
repair working out of his
garage the first six months he was there
he didn't he made i think like
fifty dollars or something some
ridiculous thing to him that was like a
million dollars
so he really enjoyed it and appreciated
it the opportunity had and
that's why we both had the same type of
spirit of just
joy and we love what we do man and um
you know he started off doing jewelry
repair and making jury
as a whole salesman for the retailers so
he also has a different perspective on
the clientele so
well that's how i teamed up with him i
was doing grills out of my trunk you
know and working out at different stores
hustling grills it was something i
teamed up with somebody to do they came
down from new york
and taught me how to do it and then from
there they brought me to johnny johnny
was the one actually making the grill
and this was around 1998
and uh at that time you know it was uh
what we was what i would see when i'm
going to put in my order for grills is
this is what would be difficult
it'd be multi-racial people as customers
but a lot of them from the hood
so it wasn't like proper english being
spoke which was
what was taught to johnny property so
johnny would be in there as a vietnamese
immigrant
in broken english and it would be all
type of races in there
speaking non-traditional english i would
be in there
i would be like the translator
and eventually it would be like you know
as my rap career kind of
ascended people would be in there like
are you following
that okay and then johnny would be like
damn man you favorite thing there man we
gotta see
what what's up really did man it really
helped my career in music as well
because
you know i could get to a lot of people
who i i could maybe do music with
that you know wanted a grill you know
that would be my introduction they
wouldn't do you agree that's why i've
you know got down with kanye hci
you know a lot of people man you know
just you know doing grills for them and
then next thing you know we doing songs
together
well and that's such a good note i
noticed a lot of
one way to get into any business is find
a way to be of service at first to the
people that are already in the business
you know
find a way to contribute and it's
amazing that the the stairways you can
make from that first step
yeah that's something we lean on to with
the jury and my music career like for my
music
i've never once ever missed the show
never missed a flight ever never been
late
you know ever i was always talk you know
if you're 15 minutes early then you're
on time
if you're on time you're late and if
you're late it's unacceptable this is
how i
always taught so i always make sure i'm
so my music career goes that way as well
as
you know you know the jury business well
you know it's all about the customer
it's a hustle business so if somebody
comes in there with a lot of money you
might not necessarily
if you come in there you might say give
me a give me a grill and you might not
know what a typical grill goes for but i
know you got money
and i know you want something nice so
it's certain ways i can word it
to make you feel like okay yeah i gotta
spend 20 30 000 on a grill when you
might only want a five hundred dollar
grill you know what i'm saying so
it's definitely a hustle game we me and
johnny though we stand on our morals and
principles so
you know it's something where we're
trying to sell you jewelry and you're
gonna bring your you
when it's mother's day you're gonna buy
you
you know on valentine's day you know all
these type of occasions you might bring
your son in to get his first starter set
of a chain you know he might bring his
kids in so
we really look at it as like you know we
ain't going nowhere so we're gonna treat
the people that our customers are gonna
treat them right
because we want them to stand on what
they buy you know they
we real about it gang man already and i
i feel like grills are kind of they're
kind of mainstream now you see everybody
rocking the
grills drake i mean you name it dave
chappelle has been seen with grills like
it now it's pretty mainstream doug
yeah man it definitely has gone
mainstream what's the most expensive
grill you guys have ever put together i
know that's
you know is there a is there somebody
that came in that just wanted it all you
know they wanted damn
just full zai or whatever it's gonna be
cheap
kanye's were like about twenty thousand
i think see i had some that were up
there uh i think the most expensive were
the ones we did for pueblo
recently uh for you know it kind of
varies because
and sometimes it's by design you know if
you von miller when they won the super
bowl he came in was like i don't care
what you tell me the price tag is i'm
paying it so you know
everybody talks a little bit more you
know
same with quavo you know he's not
lacking in the money department so he's
not
he ain't tripping on what he got to pay
but every now and then you know there
will be like a new type of setting
it's something johnny came up with
called invisible set baguette
where you you uh set the bag at diamonds
by hand
real close to each other and they it's
like a wall of diamonds with baggy
diamonds actually i got this visual set
on my bottom right here
let's go damn well you can hail a taxi
man you could just smile and hell a cab
man but when the invisible set came out
those were the most expensive and
johnny did his own all invisible step
back yet for his was like
80 000 something crazy but yeah i think
cuevos are
the most expensive right now at the time
yeah and what what's up with that whip
in the back there i'll see it's a green
screen but you still you still under the
whips
yeah that's my uh that's my slab my uh
my cadillac right there let me i got a
few others man
i'm big in the cadillacs i definitely
like the uh
i like the old school look but uh you
know the new school this new
this new ct6 is my favorite right here
this one i'm pushing right now with
detecting wire wheels on it
you know what i'm saying damn right slow
down
damn that's beautiful man well paul you
know we're big fans here man and we just
appreciate it man we appreciate you
spending some time with us man that's
really beautiful yeah we love you man
hey i love y'all too man we've been
watching out all the time me and my wife
the fam you know a lot of my partners
too man we always tune in to the king
and sting man you know saying gang gang
bug
well look we'll put a link and stuff too
if any of our you know our listeners
want to get uh get that grilled out get
grilled up man yeah
yeah baby project about to drive too man
i got this project right here in the
back it's called slope culture is
getting ready to drop
october 14th let me shout that out one
time that's sub culture
yes well and what is it
it's a new album i got i worked though i
got down with red bull studios they got
a studio over there in santa monica
on top of the line i got down with some
some of the top producers and
songwriters and we just went in man we
went in for a couple weeks right before
kobe did
actually i'm flying back from la to
houston in the midst of
right when all the kobe they debating
whether or not is you know real or is it
gonna hit us
uh right right then they both shut it
down oh they actually shut it down on my
birthday march 11th that's when
the nba shut down all kind of stuff shut
down man so uh
yeah but uh we we got this in right here
the subculture we worked it out right
before kobe had hit
and uh you know what i'm saying we're
getting ready to drop it october 14th
congrats yeah congrats well after yeah
we'll have to run one of the tracks on
here too man we'll get set up with your
people so we can run it on here and uh
and flirt the album for you thanks so
much paul for your time i appreciate you
man
are you gonna be in l.a anytime soon or
have you sit in the culture corner
yeah man i've been wanting to come on
now man i know [ __ ] asked me a while
back i really think nick i'll be putting
it off man i know he probably like
he won't respond but i really was
blowing it off trying to wait till i
could come in personally i really want
i definitely want to come [ __ ] with
y'all man
i gotta wrap that up with some grills
yeah
well look you're always welcome here
paul man you guys have a beautiful day
over there in houston man
hey for sure man yes sir yes appreciate
man
take care brother all right be good
thanks hey phil i gotta give you an lsu
shout out for my boy alex brandman
oh yeah man you ready for it huh yes sir
yes sir
i appreciate that man yeah i'm up to i'm
about to keep tabs on him man it's going
is houston playing houston's you guys
are playing right
yeah right now we were playing uh aids
yesterday but uh they
they shut it down because somebody on
the aid is set to positive for kobe and
alex
he's been hurt but i think he's about to
come back next week for a couple weeks
and say
dang man well i appreciate the uh i
appreciate the sharing the news man
um you guys be well over there paul
what's up man thank you all for having
me take care man
all right dang that's awesome
let's give it up for nick for getting
paul yeah all right
thank you thank you nick's picks it's
easy when they're a fan that's awesome
that he watches i thought for sure
you're gonna hit him with the verse
chappelle did you get the verse ready
what is it this is the one i wrapped
just give it to him let's just yeah
he'll be watching
one more time do you want to give him
the beat nick or what
which which oh you want me to wrap the
verse
yeah we want that man why do you want to
rub because you're what's up
you can watch it on brenda's instagram
that's another thing it goes hard on it
you can bring that up nick it's a good
way to
celebrate paul wall yeah damn that's so
cool dude his
his cars are dope he's a girl yeah real
cool
he's just so positive it's such a nice
dude i don't know he got the
the people's champ the tummy tuck
yeah man he said he was going to die he
was 350 man 350.
three thirds he said he was he was
climbing like the damn tesla stopped
what's the biggest you been brendan uh
go i've been 270.
that's the biggest yeah damn here it is
sheesh
is that me
mallet going wild huh
oh
it looks like timber and pumbaa huh
yeah yeah that's you guys dog yeah look
at it right there
[Laughter]
sideways too much
damn brittany you should be one of those
people that picks out uh
criminals bruh i don't know go to the
thing say who did it
he looked like morgan freeman and they'd
be like damn like damn that all right
they sketch it out
gang man that could be you you could be
me you you have so many careers man yeah
man
you're doing him bro what a great guest
his vocabulary is filthy too probably
our biggest guess we've had yet
him or uh trying to think who else we've
had him j
rod was pretty big let's not get oh how
about the uh
the lady that'd be murdering them
catfish hannah oh yeah she's huge
i guess everybody's big in their own way
too errors are so important like trevor
wallace too many he's like the biggest
star
we've had on last week who trevor
wallace oh yeah yeah yeah those those
yeah those boys were great yeah
that's one of my favorite episodes too
yeah you guys weren't here
damn i didn't i sat in for the culture
corner and
it wasn't very cultured but it was fun
yeah it wasn't culture it was still a
corner though yeah
it was a corner yeah you all talked
about culture so
yeah they probably brought their own
culture in here yeah it's probably white
culture they brought that young
white culture exactly like claw culture
yeah
which is important too yeah yeah you got
to know we don't discriminate
we don't discriminate bro you don't need
to sir no
i am why would you you know culture
matters too you know
yeah yeah what else you got nick uh we
got a king at her sting it let's move on
to the show
what up theodora vaughn and brandon
virginia shobb
james coming to you live from monroe
michigan
head of debate club for you custom
plates for your whip
king of their stinging
is that an impala is that gto what is
that that's a chevrolet man
no chevy impala
king on the back dude who gives a [ __ ]
yeah are you right that might be one of
them chevy malibu
you got that cheese in the trunk baby i
think that's a malibu
that's a malibu i'm a fan of the custom
plates because i want to get
thick boy on mine oh yeah but i think
someone has it
so i might just get thick one on my
bronco i might just get thick
than the number one whoever you bronco
whoever has it could pass away though
sorry go ahead why not thick ems
you use that a lot too it's a good idea
too my
texting buddy paul wall just said uh i
just want everybody to know
my t-shirt said burn it not bernie
i i was gonna i was gonna be like oh
you're a big bernie sanders fan to bring
it up but
you know we ended the conference and i
didn't want to get political with him
either yeah there's nothing worse when
someone goes hey give him my number
nothing's worse than people talking
politics over zoom either
yeah with three yeah white rapper and
then
those two dumbasses talking about
politics yeah that's not why we had paul
while on here
yeah that's i'm kind of excited for his
new album though me too subculture he
said it
that boy don't miss dude slappers all
the way
around yeah he got dude he got flow for
days dude so i got my grill right it's
the bottom
did i i sent you a picture nick of my
son wearing it yeah it it didn't really
lock in so my son was obsessed with it
so he wore it all day he was on a
scooter right in the ring
him i know i was like damn slow down
daddy really
slow down dude
really yeah young fella got that little
grill on from no
i sent to you right nick no yeah it's
not coming up
weird in them i wish the tie i wish i
would have got the top they only sent
the bottom
the other thing is they did the mold a
year ago at the comedy you might have
grown
i i think that's my teeth a little more
crooked maybe and then also i was
real nervous i don't want another comic
see me get my grill put in did it fast
i did it fast and behind a car what yeah
it looked like a very sketchy
translation
and the guy was like damn chill bro i
was like just get it done
oh my god damn like you're losing your
virginity or something
in high school i was nervous bill burr
would see me or rogan
yeah what are you doing over there
getting molds from my grill
yeah yeah have some pride in it yeah
have some pride in that
paul wall was with me let's see where
the grill started
we let's look at the the origins of it
yeah yeah who's the first
well i know a long time look at that
what's the song he really likes he likes
the baby oh yeah he likes the baby
yeah the baby's got grills
a long time ago when they used to have
slaves and and servants and stuff
they would put jewelry in some of them's
mouths too i really make them wear
more valuable yeah just be like this is
my
guy you know have you seen what drake's
doing these days he has a
lot of celebrities doing they just have
one diamond oh yeah
yeah that's cool you should get that
done yeah we should do it we should do
we should do it
just that one diamond hitter right there
that'd be sick
wait drake does that charge it to king
in the sting houston or memphis
they got is popular for grills right
there
yeah someone sent me a picture with uh
because i got it and then the dude who
sent
to me he's he he [ __ ] with paul wall
and his guy
he's like a tutelage under them and he's
like everybody rock them so
wear yours whenever you want i was like
yeah chill out they sent me a picture of
dave chappelle with all
diamond uh gold front on the bottom dude
i want one so bad
what about the mouth too yeah i know
if i could do it with the gap i would do
it just the bottom with you
does the bottom hit that you can wear
you
[Laughter]
i need invisalign
no down there sorry uh nine years
recession grills
first hit the airwaves but american
association is still flashing
asap rocky now keep going down until we
see some
history out there yeah that's awesome
girls are registered in each of egypt
now wouldn't braces be a form of grills
i don't know the permanent grill uh rich
intrusion
women were the first group of people to
wear what we would now call grills
certain high status etruscan women
deliberately had
their front teeth removed in order to be
fitted with a gold band appliance
holding a replacement or reused
tooth now it says you couldn't bite in
an apple with these
you couldn't buy an apple with these as
the gold usually held
replacement teeth in place and it was a
goldsmith who did it and they said it
was done to look nice
[Music]
we all need them we i mean yeah we got
to get them have y'all met ellen
nope that's why i don't judge
i judge but i have not met her oh okay
unless you're honest about it
yeah yeah i had a friend that used to be
a security guard for
and he just said that she was not cool
but i just always heard she wasn't cool
but then also i think whenever anybody
gets into too much power
people think they're not cool you know
or people that
i don't know power just corrupts
everything yeah and there's a lot of
jelly monsters out there so
she's [ __ ] killing it i like feeling
she wasn't even funny
shut the [ __ ] up she was a beast of a
comedian she was a comedian she was a
beast man
yes she has some pretty dope specials
adam carolla said she was all he knew
she was like a fake a phony because he
saw her at a wedding one time
and she didn't dance the entire time he
just saw her sit at a table for three
hours
no gangsters don't dance we boogie
and do the rockaway yeah gangsters don't
dance we boogie
do you lean back but also oh cause he
wanted her to dance all the [ __ ] time
but she talks about that like she's like
she stopped dancing that's why she hired
that twitch to dance because she's like
i'm getting sicker like whenever anybody
sees me though he's like dance and she's
like [ __ ] man
yeah again you know oh yeah that should
be your thing
dancing get out there and dance exhaust
that be every time you go out
that's like dave it's like dave
chappelle you know i'm rich [ __ ] he
said he'd be like at dinner with his
kids yeah
like i'm rich [ __ ] like dude come on
man for ellen she had to dance all the
[ __ ] time
sometimes you don't feel like dancing
monday through sunday imagine if you
have an even crazier job you know like
you're a dog catcher you're like the
best
dog catcher i think think if you're that
good
give me the dog whisperer if you're the
dog whisperer where the [ __ ] that dude
samus
will you talk to my dog yeah no [ __ ]
hey yeah leave a voicemail for my dog
for something yeah can you send my dog
attacked yeah yeah man that's crazy what
was his name caesar milan i love that
really i love watching you ever seen
caesar get bit yeah
fantastic yeah a golden retriever bit
the
[ __ ] out yup it was the golden rule and
it's about god damn time
he's always hurting he got him pretty
good he's like bleeding pretty good
that's what you get
dog [ __ ] with these dogs all the time
fake ass hoes boy
yeah out of all the dogs though he's
[ __ ] with pit bulls and gorman
great danes well he's creeping the dog
out
some weird [ __ ] right here he's always
trying to get real personal with the dog
rubbing their asses and [ __ ] all the
time
you got to rub their ass he gets bit
and you know how we're talking about
when you get hit in the head with a
football and play it off
watch this he just watch that yeah he
goes no i'm cool that's not that big of
a deal
damn
look he's like i'm good hey he's all
about dog rights i think the first thing
he just threw a [ __ ]
face what kind of kick was that
that was a charlie brown kick to the
[ __ ] sternum of that dog
damn you gotta kick it though i don't
think so look at this
[ __ ]
that can't be in his training videos is
that rockets yeah what do you do though
yeah what do you do
you don't you do that kick the golden
retriever in the [ __ ]
heart but give me a ufc breakdown what
would you do what is this this is the
clinch right
if anything you punch that thing in the
[ __ ] nose dog like a shark
don't do it kick it in the heart and try
to [ __ ] kill it
i like how all his training went out the
window he's like you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
gets on you bro you gotta [ __ ] show
that [ __ ] what's up
especially a golden retriever man that
thing ain't [ __ ] bro yeah and plus who
knows where this dog's from dude who
knows what it's been doing this dog
could have been biting people
who knows that's a problem though i got
bend in the ass by going retriever when
i was a kid and what'd you do
nothing went right nothing i should've
[ __ ] it in the heart
i didn't kick him in the heart we would
set traps we would dig holes and
make like fake leaves over it and then
have the dog walk over there
tight move yeah we would do all kind of
bad stuff because they had some
dangerous animals in our area
and that steve irwin got hit by that
stingray well the crazy
all the animals dude that cheater
stabbed that one dude on that boat that
wasn't
that whatever he was like gotcha you
cheating on your girl
it's about kind the guy's like wait what
yeah it's like cheating on your girl
he's like cool got a knife was like
ugh stem right in the [ __ ] stomach
he's like wait what
yeah it's about goddamn time you [ __ ]
snitch you gotta stab that thing larry
greco they got his ass and i met him one
time
no this isn't it it would turn out to be
fake though
no it's not fake don't ruin this [ __ ]
never mind
never mind no he got stabbed that far
down right in the stomach it's about
goddamn time bro
joey greco dude that guy's a little
[ __ ] yeah dog remember a blind date
around the show blind date i feel like
you were you ever on there or no
blind date no dude roger lodge yeah
roger lodge was a beast dude
yeah he passed away didn't even hiv hmm
[Music]
he was great that show was fans he dated
vicky gonvalsen
did he really yeah wow
breaking news which is crazy he was
great on those blind dates man
what do you mean yeah he'd have to go on
them that's why i know yeah
it's easy when your friend has to go on
there he is that [ __ ] got stabbed
finally
that's the guy that's real yeah it's
entertainment for you
you know that's my own girl she makes me
happy man she's stressful right now
i don't make you what are your what are
your plans what exactly do you think
you're responsible for here
because you can't dissociate yourself
from the responsibility of this child
and that's what it looks like it looks
like your personal space
so now you don't care when we get home
i'm going to finish my opponent you're
not coming home
we can't tell on the face kinda looks
like
[ __ ] he's bleeding oh my god bleeding
easy ease him out of here oh my god [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that shit's real bro it's real to me
dude you crazy bro you're supposed to be
working at the prison bro
yeah this is crazy that's a that's a
fake that man is fake bro that little
nerd deserves to be
stabbed bro dude i'll bite that dude
with a sharp ass grill bruh
dude how did him or the homeboy who
catch the predator how did the cat's
predator dude never get
[ __ ] up because i think he had people
in such a tough like
those people were not fighting him
they're like i'm getting the f what am i
gonna fight him and then hook up with
the kids
yeah that's insane i know these people
are insane on the show dude i watched
one it was it was they didn't release it
was this big fat dude he gets there
and you feel sorry for the dude he's
like i'm fat i can't get a girl
i'm trying to lose weight and then
homeboy starts talking about his diet
and how he's the loser all of a sudden
you feel bad for him
we talked to him he came on uh this past
weekend yeah he stole money from you
guys
yeah yeah well he did some yeah he did
some maybe unsultry behavior
what i would say is this that he um
yeah i felt bad for the pedophile
sometimes
there's this one it's like it's a big
fat dude and he starts crying
and i felt bad for him because for the
pedophiles
yeah and i showed people you shouldn't
feel bad for them yeah you should
nah [ __ ] them i still have like i have
zero emphasis wait do you have kids
oh and i don't i feel worse for the kids
but i still feel bad that this dude has
some affliction where he's out there
pedophilia
it's obviously a sickness but then
there's also have you heard of dad i
don't want to be no pedophile have you
heard dads against
pedophiles have you seen it it's a
youtube show d-a-p dap
zap it up them boys them boys doing the
lord's work
they always need a real target yeah be
like what's your entire like i don't
know you
but then how did i know you were here
he's like i don't know and how do you
know little lance and lance
who i watched that last one that [ __ ]
pictures beth this bet
this [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] predator hell yeah she's a predator
dragon a 15 year old girl
is beth right here and they do a great
job on the
editing no this is an ad
fast forward this that's like the
beginning yeah it's this little
start here um i'd go to the text convo
yeah that's how you know some real
pedophile heartbreaking man
she tried getting her husband involved
this show is going downhill i'll say
this
nah this is the lord it's good we're
giving them some publicity oh
please tell me you're up for fun tonight
staying at the hilton downtown iowa
oh sorry for being blunt l-o-l well i'm
here my sister would care if i was
younger are you at least 18
question mark
[Music]
no i'm not eight i'm not 18 how old are
you 17. well first of all they also use
the term
downtown iowa city
very vague term i've been iowa city dude
there's not really a downtown there's
one big building where you meet at
though apparently
i guess
oh bro this is making me sick
you got sympathy for this [ __ ] huh you
got sympathy for her
no oh she's the woman that was texting
the girls
it was a couple it was a couple they
were trying to get to come together and
she goes i was coming here to delete the
messages
her eyebrow frown is intense right
it looks like she's got the tesla logo
[Laughter]
[Music]
these are dads doing work bro caps
yeah her face moves a lot but it just
this
moves
did yeah did so after this is over
i watched one where they that they meet
this kid at a at a [ __ ] uh
basically a target damn man and he's
like i was just here getting drinks
and then he calls his dad he goes what's
your dad going to do because we'll see
where my dad comes and he's like
what the [ __ ] what's your dagger he says
i'll call the cops we want
what we'll share the tax convo with the
cops and the dad what is a sexual
predator
probably oh god damn have any of you
guys ever been predator
have they come for sex yeah again this
you know i was in that cute little kid i
was too angry
no one wanted to [ __ ] with me man i'm
sorry
but also back in the day we didn't have
social media and techs and stuff
so they have to get you the traditional
way they'd usually roll up in a white
van around virginia court elementary
school shout out to the tigers
in the van they would have cadbury eggs
and i would jump in the back
damn you eat eat those eggs bro it
sounds like you got molasses
nope i was just eating eggs i had a
combo and i'd jump on out
pick me up well look man i don't want to
be talking about pedophilia too much
man it's just too much who's birthday
whose birthday is his birthday
hopefully whoever's birthday it is it's
an 18 year old
i'd say 21 at this point even 18's a
little dice i'm not
i'm saying for these dang kids man
people out here everybody getting
molested at a damn courtyard yeah you
ever had someone try to come after you
and kidnap you in a van
uh not kidnap me in a van but a lot of
release
uh like such [ __ ] happens when i was
younger i was like a little girl hanging
out around my aunt's coffee shop and
there's a lot of older men
who liked younger girls so i didn't get
it at the time they would touch her hair
like biden
all right oh no that's the thing like
it's just one listen you can kind of
feel
them like i [ __ ] you from afar it's
weird because they look like my uncles
disgusting that's why i leave my eyes in
the car dude
i put my eyes in the cup holder dog well
look i want to say this
point blank man i'm not a pedophile bro
there you go you know what i'm saying i
remember i was in college and
it was statistics or whatever class and
the professor was at the front of the
class like 600 kids in there
sure and he goes statistically uh one of
you guys will die in a car accident
um one of you guys will be uh we'll work
uh for a fortune 500 company
and one of you guys will be uh the
pedophile will be
will be convicted of a registered and
he's right and i stood up and yelled not
it
didn't everybody there you go there you
go [ __ ] crazy
let me try this out right now dude i
remember one year
i remember at cu football the only white
guy in the running backs room and the
coach sits down you can
tell he's having a long day it's me and
all black guys and he's probably saying
goes
man i just read a city there's eight of
us in he goes i just went up because i
just read a statistic he was
one in six men is gay there's eight of
you in here
and it just stayed standing it was like
that
and everyone was all silent and then
everyone picked on one kid they're like
terry's gay
[Laughter]
no i'm not who do you think it is out of
this room
there's six men in here
[Laughter]
we're all in relationships
i'm a relationship with the lord brother
and that's the strongest bond you can
have
it is a gay relationship
so you are it it is man to man bro i
guess
i'm spiritually gay good for you i'm gay
for god
that's a crew game for god oh is it
really you bend the knee just to a man
that's henry
what else you got nick yeah in wisconsin
i'm sure you've had some dudes roll up
on you with some cheese a nice cut
sharp chicken yeah i've only met nice
older men the nicest
red children i don't know i was an altar
boy for uh from kindergarten sixth grade
but i think they
thought i would tell on him
no they were really nice guys somebody
looked up to him yeah there you go
yeah i even janitor at the rectory on
weekends on occasion
the craziest part of that check check is
the old guy comes down the middle of the
aisle and just sprinkles everybody
yeah yeah that's the part where it's
like whoa
they were all really good people man
just nothing that's christ bro
yeah um that's how it should work and
you were on the church cheerleading team
give me a g
give me an l give me an a give me him
give me a b
that's the lamb baby no i was not on the
church cheerleading team there we go
is there a church cheerleading team
there probably is yeah like
aggressive p.e aggressive yeah probably
like just a little christian youth group
they probably haven't like something i
bet they
suck if you became the church
cheerleader dog
dolla dolla bills don't have to pay
taxes around the country doing backflips
for the lord
another brilliant business idea i don't
know how many of those backflips i got
left in
tighten up dude you gotta do the lord's
help you could do a ton of them
he's got a point yeah dude you start
doing
christian back flips you're slinging
barbecue yeah then host the game
the christ is right the crisis is right
come on down
wins i flip come on up come on come on
up
come on up because that's what lord i
lift your name on high yeah
the mountain climber goes to uh heaven
instead yeah oh
yeah you fall off go to hell yeah here
you go man
jesus christ i mean how many ideas
we got a lot of beautiful ideas for me i
think how many ideas you've done with
one you know
yeah i am and when you run with the lord
you can never lose
yep you can't lose man so who else got
melissa chen
you're a big korean kid in texas i'm
sure
i didn't get molested but there was a
there was a strange
guy that was supposedly like a nice
person he worked at the church
so me and my friends this was when i was
what keep going
yeah keep going we're just listening to
you so he lived in the neighborhood
yep and then he would ask us to hang out
and then
he would talk about god you know how
great god is and we would ask him like
questions like
oh if you go to heaven can you
skateboard all day because we're you
know in the skateboarding so he's like
yeah i could do everything question
praise god stupid question the the
people the parents didn't like him
but we thought he was the nicest nicest
guy because he's worked at the church
and everything sure
he smoked cigarettes okay he had long
hair okay
and then once one day he was talking
about how baptizing is awesome and great
yeah so he baptized us in his backyard
with his pants with the water water hose
with a water hose yeah he goes it
doesn't matter where the water comes
from it just has to be blessed dude just
want to see some boys wet
in the summer i'm looking back i think
maybe you know maybe
something could have happened if we
didn't like yeah you sure it was a water
healer's dude
he could have painted his wiener green
and put a little metal on the end of it
yeah yeah
somebody it's a hot day it's worth it
just popped up right now i kind of just
i'm glad you got it out though thanks
dude everybody got a little bit molested
and i know that um
they had a man by us that was a
religious type of man you know
and he uh he used to get us high
then he would get us weed you know and
at the time we thought he was cool guy
that's how it goes looking back he was
70 year old man
hanging out buying weed for 15 year olds
and why is he doing it so it's a little
dicey
high enough you think his dick is a
playground i mean it's cool yeah but
it's a little dicey you know
hell yeah it's dicey like hey you want
to slide down this short slide
whoa you want to jump on these monkey
bars but he would get us high and then
he bought us some baked potatoes one
time this dude richard bangenstein was
his last name
definitely dead alarming name he is dead
hot potatoes he got us some steaks and
potatoes and we never had steaks and
potatoes he sounds like a nice guy to be
honest
that's where we were at this point
brendan and then what happened was
everybody got high and was eating their
meal and i was in the
kitchen and i said hey does anybody want
some
uh sour cream i yelled that
and my buddy scott goes uh you can have
some of this sweet oh
my buddy scott goes hey will you give me
some sour cream and i said no but i'll
get you some of this sweet cream you
know
i was talking about semen making jokes
[Laughter]
and then he goes can i have some oh
and then were you like check please
it was like i think we're good on that
guy all the breaks in my head just
slammed on
and i was like damn this dude's gonna
molest somebody and i didn't even tell
my friends
i was just like i gotta get out of here
and then friends keep going back eating
potatoes and sweet cream that's their
life bro
you know they'll have to share their
story when they're ready
theo had a lot of stuff happening we had
a basketball coach pam to look at his
butthole from 20 feet away
it's true he had another older man uh
make him lick cinnamon out of his hand
wait what hold on
you want to have a seat
[Laughter]
whoa what's up with the cinnamon liquid
my dad's friend man
so what so he was like hey you like
churros you're like yeah
he's like all right go ahead and try
this [ __ ] finger
no man he had a little bit of cinnamon
this one not everybody had cinnamon man
not everybody had it you know
and you think there wasn't a bunch of
his hand like a bird
so someone so if someone had it it was
like damn you got cynical he would sneak
you a little behind his back you know
lick it out was it the powder or the
stick it was the powder
okay cause i used to chew on the sticks
so what happened
yeah and that's not moleski at all
you dude if you look you know who choose
on the sticks
chew on the sticks and suck on the beans
you know you chewed on the sticks
somebody that started on the powder
that's for sure
so and then what happened to the
basketball coach you looked at your
butthole yeah you know this guy used to
pay us give us a little bit of money and
he would show his
behold about 40 feet off well this is
you know
polite i guess i mean this is a
different time man everything wasn't a
crime back then and we thought he was
crazy
no matter what year you're in you know
if you call the police you're like hey
some guy's showing me his pedal from 40
feet away
to kids they're gonna arrest that dude
yeah brother you see you see they're not
see but you're you're a victim
you're a victim you think it's all good
you know justifying it oh come on gary
was cool
man well what happened was let's eat
cinnamon
the cops knew us and they knew our
neighbor this lady miss cheryl had a car
that had a
alarm on it yeah it was like the first
car alarm in our
in our area and so he's like go out
there and push cheryl's car
and that'll scare him off that's what
that's what the cop said
so he got there and shake her car and
then the alarm would go off and then
anything that was going on that
shouldn't have been people would tighten
up that makes sense
damn damn here's my brother right here
close out this guy he's piecing pretty
high oh okay
looks like my brother jay
yo what up deal what up brandon grandma
carter from salt lake city right now
hey would you hang out with snoop dogg
and play them this is from easy e
or would you just kick it with them and
play his old [ __ ]
game game buzz buzz
just listen to old [ __ ] smoke for pedro
huh yeah
big thrasher fan too
napoleon dynamite smoke for pedro yeah
wow i'd rather hang out with him than
snoop dogg
calvin brodice man he's getting older
kevin brodis he has to be a damn near
60.
no he's like he's not even 50 years old
he's a pioneer
i bet you bring that [ __ ] up bring that
[ __ ] up you're telling me he's not 50.
he is not 50. i'm 37. you tell me
what does that age say forty-eight
forty-eight
damn they're fifteen here but he's not
they fake that he ain't 48
man him and cameron diaz went to the
same high school well yeah
a lot of people went to high school he
would probably want a different year
also his cornrows are back here
first of all they're not cornrows
anymore they're dreads when he changed
the snoop lion
he's not still snoop blind i know he's
not but he got those dreads
you know and they just kept growing you
know uh i think no man both y'all
sweating this dude like y'all trying to
bang and bro or touches yeah i love
snoop dogg man
i'll show my [ __ ] from 40 feet away
40 feet away
y'all ain't [ __ ] i'll give you hate that
old school move man that won't even get
you molested i'll tell you right now
i'll eat cinnamon out of snoop dog's
hand right
right like a little baby bird bro now
we're talking yeah
now we talking pure that's teamwork
no snoop had to change his name because
uh uh death row
death row because knight owned his
rights and master p was like
when suge knight was in prison was okay
i won by snoop dogg's rights
i think he had to pay like 10 million
he's like but you can't call
he can't call him snoop anymore no you
can't call him snoop doggy dog yeah so
he's just
a snoop dogg just snoop yup come on i
heard he's been yeah sharing a lot of
weird news snope dog have you guys seen
that
just a bad snopes jokes snoop a loop
you ever seen him live nope good a lot
of crips
keep gripping a lot of christmas yeah
well cause he's a [ __ ] right yeah
yeah he was threatening takashi 69 too
you remember that saying he's a rat
yeah yeah this is all urban talk deal so
i'm fine yeah they're all doing the [ __ ]
walk on stage which is dope i love the
[ __ ]
yeah can you see your block yeah a
little bit i can't a little bit myself
yeah dude nobody's messing with y'all
weak ass crap
santa claus outfit really let me see it
yeah i'll [ __ ] walk for some cinnamon
and out of your hand
right now the weakest ass crips bro
[ __ ] what
the other kind of dude that was a [ __ ]
he's the kind of guys bring a barbecue
sauce to a gun fight bro
y'all the freaking worst ass chris i'll
send it to nick right now
quick walking in the center it's a legit
[ __ ] walk your pot your your daddy [ __ ]
bug
yeah i don't ask him a lot of questions
about the gang life
really oh i would dude it'd be like if
he wants to tell me dude if your dad
comes in
it's going to be like an episode of gang
land it's more fantastic
here's what we need to do is make sure
he does that thing where he yells at
somebody that has
that's a child what's that thing called
beyond scared straight oh yeah
oh scarecrow let's have your dad let's
have your dad scare us straight not to
[ __ ] walk anymore
oh excuse me not quit walking me and
theo you're probably not scared of your
dad we are
i would be he's a great guy is he my my
whole family the our origin is uh
louisiana y'all from louisiana your dad
is mm-hmm what part no no
uh his his uh dad nor
mom his mom's side of the family they're
all what part do you know
no i don't know did you text that yeah
it just texts well kind of what kind of
[ __ ] we're talking about here that the
hoover
who my dad's from arizona
right yeah dude here let me see that hat
try this one yeah
you look like charlie daniels brown look
at that right there
let me see this crib box oh
oh damn i'm back now boy hell yeah
damn that's santa's lip
oh there it is oh damn you know
where the hose at
[Laughter]
where's the cinnamon at you feel me
daddy where's the scent
yeah yeah bro i love how nobody else is
in christmas attire though that's the
best thing i love how the white people
are so
out of this look at them
oh my gosh who brought that santa
that's a dirty chimney
and nick's right back here there he is
[Music]
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ate the queso and the quesoritos
but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
king and a sting king and a sting oh
yeah
king and a sting beast
[Music]
on a string